william colleen and his daughter are
fighting for their house a small
terrorist house in the working class
district of dublin carburetor
the plumber obtained a small mortgage
during islands construction boom but
then lost his job in the financial
crisis and defaulted on his payments
now the banks want to foreclose on his
home
it's actually being paid you know i mean
and he gave us actually no time
whatsoever it was
it was sent here maybe was she brought
here say on a
wednesday or tour see i think and then
you know we had to be over here for
the following wednesday you know it's
only
a week's time you know and that's it
basically you went to twenty thousand up
front after erase
and there was no way that we could get
twenty thousand
and we
said we wouldn't be in a position to
have twenty thousand we wouldn't be in
this situation in the first place if we
had twenty thousand
and come and just continue paying the
mortgage we have that we're able to pay
that we're able to keep up the payments
and
and
no they weren't on it
according to jerry beads the colleen
family is one of about 500 000
the building contractor has set up an
organization called the land league to
help people fight for their homes
he tries to find compromises with the
banks
what's so idiotic is that responsibility
falls back on the state after these
people are evicted and as the bank has
already been bailed up at the state the
state is now going to have to pay a
second time round the taxpayers on the
hook for the second time around because
in our constitution these people are
entitled to be housed by the state and
so it's it's economic madness
irish taxpayers also have another
problem
ireland's banks offloaded the worst of
their toxic assets into the state's bad
bank vehicle the national asset
management agency or nama which was set
up to buy 71 billion euros of property
loans in a bid to save the economy from
collapse
now nama is selling off the properties
for hard cash
nama expects to yield a profit for the
taxpayer and do we want nama to continue
its work as quickly as possible yes we
do do we want nama to continue to
deliver a social dividend yes we do but
it is important to acknowledge that nama
is now likely to yield a profit for the
exchequer
ross mcguire says that the social
dividends are not as high as they could
be
he'd hoped to buy this modern dublin
theater and transform it into a
government-owned foundation
he raised 20 million euros but large
private investors got there first
nama didn't want to negotiate
when it was set up it has a social
purpose it has never seen fit to be
involved in a social purpose it's just a
giant sales agency now it's completely
uh it lacks transparency nobody knows
what goes on inside there we just know
it sells and it has a high turnover of
staff some of its senior staff go to
work for investors then so the whole
thing is
unsatisfactory
lacks transparency unsatisfactory
no one at nama was willing to respond to
the allegations on camera
but that's only part of the problem
nama only bought up large commercially
viable loans
it didn't buy up the debts of hundreds
of thousands of small and medium-sized
investors that the banks are still
sitting on
jerry beads put 10 million into this
building and now the only thing to do is
tear it down
we're looking at 50 half built
apartments
um
underground car park built
and um
whole thing has been lying here since
july 2009
such investment ruins are ticking time
bombs for the banks and there are an
estimated 200 000 empty houses and
apartments in ireland the situation for
the irish banks is that you know they're
all sitting on a pile of trash
and
it's not getting any better
though house prices are beginning to
rise and ireland seems to have got over
the worst of the crisis the echoes of
the real estate crash will resonate for
some time